we have a voicemail number that number
is
2192 David P
today's caller
asks a very personal question
about parenting
listen to this
hi David are you the kind of father that
would spank your children and wife
no
no I I don't even do do I really need to
say more I mean do
the answer is is no
uh let's just leave it there we have a
fantastic bonus show for you today
the World Cup has started in Qatar
I am genuinely
split 50 50. on the one hand I could not
be more disgusted at the lead up so let
me listen
corruption in the selection of Qatar to
even host a World Cup
use of what is essentially slave labor
indentured servitude to build the
stadiums in Qatar most recently Qatar
won't allow any kosher food or public
Jewish prayer
in and around the World Cup this is a
horrible
extremist authoritarian regime
on the other hand as an Argentinian
I love the world cup and I love watching
the Argentinian Men's National Team I'm
thinking about getting up at 5am
tomorrow to watch the first game
and this is
um we're going to talk about World Cup
and what's going on in Qatar on the
bonus show that's number one secondly
CBS News went on Hiatus from Twitter
after
supposedly over security concerns
and then is now back to posting on
Twitter what happened is it weird is it
a call for attention what's going on we
will discuss it
and thirdly NASA is now saying that by
the year 2030 this is only you know
eight years away at this point by the
year 2030
astronauts will be living and working on
the moon you know we heard all these
predictions about we would be on Mars by
2024 we're not going to be
um
etc etc that don't seem plausible they
never seemed plausible Mars 2028 it's
seeming a little difficult but maybe
working and living on the Moon by 2030
seems much more plausible but will it
happen and what would be the point we're
going to talk about those stories and
more on today's bonus show this is a
shortened week just so everybody knows
we are here Monday Tuesday Wednesday we
will then be off the rest of the week
for the Thanksgiving federal holiday in
the United States Monday Tuesday
Wednesday will sort of be like a Friday
show and we will have new content on the
Pacman Finance Channel we will have new
content on Pac-Man Live everything else
will sort of be normal but it'll just be
a shortened week for the holiday and
then we will be indeed uh back next week
we're going to speak to you on the bonus
show you can sign up at
joinpakman.com oh the bonus show where
you want to make money yeah everybody
else that makes money to fund themselves
is bad yeah Alex Jones is the last
person at this point to be commenting on
business advice given what's going on
with his hemorrhaging of money uh but
yes you sign up at joinpackman.com you
can use the coupon code 24 starts now
and very soon maybe tomorrow
maybe Wednesday
I will be able to announce the release
of our first white paper
I think you're going to like this talk
to you on the bonus show or otherwise
tomorrow
I love cooking at home I cook all the
time having a good set of knives that
you actually like to use is really
important for years I have been a fan of
the advantages that Japanese knives
offer and our sponsor kamikoto makes
amazing Japanese steel kitchen knives
using the traditional techniques that
date back to the Edo period of Japan
kamikoto only uses steel from Japan each
blade takes years to craft and goes
through a rigorous 19-step inspection
process with a lifetime guarantee the
knives come in a beautiful heavy duty
Ash wood box makes it a really great
gift easy to store as well on the
kamikota website you can see a map of
the Michelin star chefs all over the
world using kamikoto knives my kamikoto
knives at home have been performing
great for years you really just can't
beat the feel of a nice Japanese knife
perfectly balanced in your hand and
kamikoto is now running a big Black
Friday sale my audience gets an extra
fifty dollars off go to kamikodo.com
Pacman and use the code Pacman the link
is down below